let's turn to the growing problem of
plastic pollution across the world
and a pioneering way of dealing with it
the great pacific
garbage patch in the pacific ocean
contains plastic waste
twice the area of the state of texas oh
yeah
kenya is one of the many countries
contributing to this pollution
hundreds of tons of plastic waste are
created every day
just in nairobi the capital as part of
our eye on earth series deborah patta
met with a young woman who's come up
with one potential solution
this is dundora about 30 acres of waste
that's the equivalent of 22 football
fields
despite a pioneering plastic ban kenya
is still
drowning in it and whilst most people
look at this and think it's an
insurmountable plastic mountain
one young woman saw a way to move that
mountain
there are days in kenya when you can
actually walk on water
this river is choking with so much
plastic
it's formed an unsinkable foundation a
disturbing health hazard for
everyone living here except this young
woman
so i get i get excited when i see waste
because i know that's
that's that's life for us
the fact that plastic does not sink is
precisely what intrigued material
scientists
in zambia matia i came across this
concept of using plastic to building box
in 2017 kenya outlawed single-use
plastic bags but it's still everywhere
clogging drains polluting rivers
contaminating animal feed
some of it ends up here in nairobi's
dundora landfill
which long reached its capacity and was
supposed to be closed down
20 years ago but every day waste pickers
trudge
through the rancid trash sifting for
plastic
plastic that matia had to figure out how
to turn
into bricks when you made your first
brick
how was that
that was the best day it took us about
nine months
just to make one break but one break
wasn't enough
no problem for a woman who likes to get
her hands and
pretty much everything else dirty
so she built a machine to mass produce
the plastic bricks
first the waste is sorted to remove
rubble and metals
and then you're going to bake it exactly
figure if you know how to make cookies
this is just making cookies i could make
a brick are you saying
exactly the boiling mixture is molded
into building blocks as many as 2 000 a
day
35 cheaper than standard bricks and up
to seven
times stronger
pretty impressive yep it doesn't break
currently materials bricks are only used
for pathways in small households
but she wants to target big construction
companies next
compounding kenya's fight against
plastic is that two years ago
the us exported more than one billion
pounds of plastic waste
to 96 nations including kenya and
now wants to make the shipment of
plastic a condition of a proposed
trade deal greenpeace activist amar
suamanya
believes kenya can barely manage its own
waste
let alone recycle americas it will be
importing more problems
if we were to allow this u.s kenya
threat deal to be used
as a way of damping plastic west on the
african continent
matia agrees countries should keep their
waste in their own backyards
and she intends to make good on what she
calls her
triple threat the more we recycle the
plastic
the more we produce the affordable
housing problem the more we created more
employment for the youth
which means there's no time to get too
comfortable for cbs this morning
deborah patter nairobi kenya
well based on that u.n report time is
running out we've got to find solutions
this is one of them yeah well
i mean we could probably use some of
those bricks here in america and what a
sales uh
person that that woman is scientist and
sales person and just the excitement
over it too you can't help but join her
in some of that great great use